TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
We recently released the final
SDK for Android Wear 2.0.
This release has added support
for new hardware features,
material design for
Android Wear, watch face
complications, and more.
All the details are on the
post, linked in the description
below.
We also released Developer
Preview 2 for Android Things,
bringing new features and
bug fixes to the platform.
A summary of changes
and links to the code
are on the post,
where you'll also
find a really cool sample that
shows how to use TensorFlow
on Android Things devices,
using an early access TensorFlow
inference library
pre-built for Arm and X86.
It demonstrates
accessing the camera,
performing object recognition
and image classification,
and speaking out the results
using text to speech.
TensorFlow Fold makes it easy
to implement deep learning
models that operate over data
of varying size and structure.
It also brings the benefits
of batching to such models,
resulting in a speedup
of more than 10x on CPU,
and more than 100x on GPU over
alternative implementations.
Links to the paper and
GitHub are on the post.
Google Cloud Endpoints is a
fast, scalable API gateway,
and is now generally available.
It features a server
local proxy and is
built on the same services
that Google uses to power
its own APIs.
More details and
links to get started
on the post, linked in
the description below.
Please subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
we'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching this week's
episode of The Developer Show.
For more of our
previous episodes,
click on the lovely links
to my left, your right.
Right there.
Yeah.
[TELEPHONE DIALING]